eleven days since nor
on a holiday in Malaysia today answers
for her heartbroken family about what
happened to the 15 year old at the
hospital more where days earlier Nora's
family had identified her body this
morning police told reporters there was
no evidence a teenager was abducted my
wheelchair come with this body the cause
of death is intestinal bleeding that was
most likely caused by lack of food for a
long period of time we believed that
Nora died two to three days before she
was found or not more than four days and
there's no sign of sexual assault or any
sign of rape nor a Quarren had severe
learning difficulties and had never
wandered off alone before her family say
her disappearance was out of character
they had been staying at a resort about
50 miles from Kuala lumper when the 15
year old went missing from the Doosan
hotel local tribes with knowledge of the
dense jungle were called in to help the
search and on Tuesday nine days after
she vanished
Nora's body was found near a waterfall
just over a mile from where she went
missing Malaysian police say the
teenager had bruises on her legs but
that these would not have caused her
death they believed she could have died
because of stress and a lack of food
Nora's family who've described their
daughter as the most precious girl will
now be able to fly her body home Ali
Fortescue Sky News